[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Jason is
in Shreveport hi Jason how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
okay so I'm 40 years old I am a
classically trained opera singer and
music teacher when I was 27 I was
working on my PhD I had a grand mal
seizure that year the next year I had
another grand mal seizure I was
diagnosed with epilepsy fast forward to
2020 I had my second brain surgery three
weeks before we went into lockdown wow
they removed they removed 10 of my brain
um I'm on the mend in terms of the
epilepsy but
there is no cure for epilepsy it's never
going away what is not going away is my
student loan debt
so when I go to try and buy a house they
factor in one percent of that total
amount as a monthly payment that I'm not
making because I'm on an income driven
repayment plan
and I have tried to file for the total
disability discharge and was denied why
apparently well because they said that
my my uh epilepsy wasn't severe enough
however when I went through the
disability process it was a retired
gynecologist making the decision as to
whether or not I would be so you're not
on SSI you're not on Social Security
I am now finally it took permanent
disability
no well it's not permanent I I have to
re-re-qualify every three to five years
I'm waiting on that next uh set of
paperwork well the retired gynecologist
didn't do that that didn't get you into
SSI
well
you had to have another there had to be
another medical professional
professional on that part of the story
right
well I have a I have a neurologist uh
like a epileptologist and uh and they
gave me the paperwork for the for the
Social Security Administration to
approve the SSI disability
that's correct okay and your your your
uh Denial on the student loan idiots was
before you got this SSI approved
no no
they said my condition was not severe
enough
the answer to the equation is I'm not
stopping on that dude you're disabled
fair enough okay okay yeah the answer is
I'm gonna go Congressman Senator uh uh
I'm gonna hire an attorney uh you got
300 000 wrapped around your neck that's
not going away that should be forgiven
is that how much debt it is Jason yeah
that's how much I have in my name my
wife my wife so I have 297
000 in student loan debt starting in
um my wife also has an additional two
she's now a college professor making
Hawaii
she's a tenure track Professor making
fifty one thousand dollars she just got
this job this year we just moved a month
ago
it's a really good job for her
now I was hoping to have the same kind
of position but without my exit degrees
help me with this because I'm sorry I'm
struggling with 51 000 and we call that
a good job
so tell me how this works she's on a
tenure track does that mean she's gonna
be making 120 in three or four years
we don't know the final number but once
she's granted tenure and seven years the
income does go up drastically yeah and
it should go up incrementally between
now and then also
I'm hopeful that that 51 000 of a PhD
teaching at the University level sounds
low period whether there's tenure or not
I agree okay I agree it's uh it's a
tough world out there uh no it's not
that I mean I'm telling you it's not
that's not right that's too low other
phds are teaching at the college level
make a lot more than that that's what
I'm saying so I don't know whether this
is the particular University she got on
with uh or maybe it's the degree of
field I don't know uh but
um so the answer to her 200k is for you
guys to get your income up and get rid
of it the answer to your 300K is good
God is uh half a million dollars is uh
for you to go after these guys on the
disability issue because I mean you've
if one the trick with a disability with
them is to get if the Social Security
Administration has declared you're
disabled and puts you on SSI that should
be the ticket
and I should just straight up forgive it
now is there a difference with it not
being permanent the fact that he has to
reapply every three to five years
you have to look at all the time anyway
you know if you become undisabled you're
not you know you you lose that but yeah
that
I I'm telling you man I am spending some
energy and some time with uh Senators
Congressman staff uh and an attorney and
I'm gonna get this calling if I'm in
your shoes I think I think that should
be forgiven that's what it's for I mean
upon death or disability federally
insured student loans but disability
isn't I feel bad disability is the
Social Security Administration has
declared you disabled and that's that's
the debt that's the definition for
purposes of student loan forgiveness and
that's a standard program that is not a
Joe Biden helped you out that's that's
been from day one that program has been
there yeah wow Jason I'm so sorry you
guys are facing this what a horrible
process y'all have been through
and the student loans have just made it
worse
so um man that's awful
um and at risk of sounding like I'm
piling on him because I'm not
um but that should that kind of a phone
call to this show should be a warning to
some of you
that you don't go two hundred thousand
dollars in debt to get your PhD to make
50 Grand
okay those numbers don't work and you
don't go three hundred thousand dollars
in debt to Live Your Dream in the uh
Opera world because you could end up
with a medical condition and end up in a
mess and it probably isn't even that
lucrative of a well I mean it is if it
is it's it's uh you know but it's it's
like anything else in the music business
it's there's a percentage that make all
the money and a percentage that wish
they did and um so but either way the
you cannot bet five hundred thousand
dollars on these tracks
that's not this is what gets you in
trouble and because then life happens
and you end up here and I'm gosh Jason
I'm so sorry you're there I'm not
picking on you but the rest of you
should take a warning from this and if
you got a kid wanting to go on this
track tell them no no we're not doing
this no